Hi there,
I guess I'm on.
My son isn't here tonight,
so I'm doing this in my
relatively technologically clueless
manner.
Um,
here's one thing I've noticed about
getting older.
I have
kept up with computer technology pretty
well I would say,
but I do find maybe because of the
demands on me in the last year,
maybe I'm not stupid or it's possible.
So anyways.
Hi everyone.
Nice to see you here.
It looks like I've got the chat working.
Is Everything working?
Looks like it.
All right,
so I'm going to start with some
questions that people sent me.
Anyways.
Thank you for all beat,
all of you for being here.
By the way.
It's very much appreciated.
It's quite remarkable as far as I'm
concerned that you tune in to listen to
me talk with you.
I definitely do appreciate it.
So I'm going to start with some of the
questions that people sent me earlier
and I'll keep an eye on the chat youtube
chat as well.
So,
um,
hopefully the audio is good.
What about that?
How's the audio guys?
So now Adam,
w dot Patterson asked me a question that
got 410 volts.
He said,
um,
I am a web software developer.
Are you hiring or can I volunteer for
anything?
I can build anything.
I can automate things.
I could simply be an assistant of sorts.
Thank you for your time.
Well,
what I would like to say about that is
first thank you out.
It's much appreciated on a lot of people
have volunteered their time to me and
their and their technological expertise
and as much as I'd like to make use of
it.
That simple truth of the matter is that
I'm sufficiently overwhelmed by the
complexity of my life at the moment,
that it's very difficult to undertake a
new collaborative project with anyone
mean generally speaking,
before all this political,
um,
what would you call it before all these
political events overtook my life.
I was already scheduled probably about
six months to a year out.
You know,
all my was already eaten up.
And of course,
the addition of everything that's
happened in the last year or two that
has occupied my time to a degree that
is,
was,
is really somewhat unimaginable.
And so I just can't take on additional
help,
which is so strange because you think
that help is help and that it would save
time,
but,
you know,
it's very difficult to enter into a
collaborative relationship with someone
and especially if you want to give them
credit and do things properly.
So,
um,
at the moment I'm afraid that I can't
entertain any such offers even though
I'd like to.
And there may come a time in the future,
especially when I'm hopefully starting
to work more on this online university
project.
Um,
I've got a few projects to finish up
before that to the new personality
tasks,
which we've just about got all the bugs
worked out of.
And also the high school version of the
future authoring program are all.
We're all set up long before any of this
happened.
So I have to clear them out before I can
concentrate on a new project that I
finished a book over the last couple of
years to called a 12 rules for life and
antidote to chaos,
which is now available by the way,
if you're interested on Amazon for
preorder.
Um,
and so anyways,
this is my roundabout way of saying
thank you very much,
but I can't accept more help at the
moment because my time is too restricted
to make proper use of it.
So I'm clay's nor,
and how to use the results in the new
personality tests for progress in life.
Try to compensate some sites that that
received fewer points.
Well,
at the risk of sounding self serving.
That's actually why we developed the
self authoring suite was to help people
improve their,
let's say performance and mental health.
Now we don't have direct evidence that
will,
that will improve personality,
but I suspect that that evidence would
take a very long time to accumulate.
What we do know is that the self
authoring suite,
especially the future authoring suite,
helps people,
helps university students,
for example,
stay enrolled in university.
It increases the probability of that by
about 25 percent and increased his grade
point average by about the same.
And there's good theoretical reasons for
assuming that writing is a good way of,
of um,
as writing about yourself and about your
past and about your future is a good way
of catalyzing personality transformation
because it appears that personality,
the human psyche is organized at the
highest level of abstraction.
Using something like self narrative and
a well developed narrative makes a frame
for your life and helps you stabilize
your negative emotions and also
experienced more positive emotion
because you only experienced positive
emotion in relationship to a goal.
And that can make goal directed activity
a lot more rewarding.
So you know,
it's a lot easier to engage in
activities that aren't intrinsically
rewarding if they're linked to something
that you really find important.
And so I would say if you want to work
on your personality,
well,
the first thing you have to do is figure
out who it is that you want to be.
And then you have to make a plan and
maybe you have to clean up your past as
well.
And the self authoring suite was
designed quite carefully in order to
help people do that with a relative
minimum of effort.
Not that it's easy because it's not,
but a relative minimum minimum of effort
compared to other technologies,
let's say,
and like,
like longterm psychotherapy and to make
it cost effective as well.
So.
Okay.
So another question voted up 77 votes.
Australia is holding a plebiscite on
whether to legalize gay marriage.
I'm against the yes campaign,
but only because it's backed by Cultural
Marxists.
I'm curious to hear your views on gay
marriage.
Well,
I would be against,
it was backed by Cultural Marxists
because it isn't clear to me that,
um,
it will satisfy the ever increasing.
What would you call a demand for an
assault on traditional modes of being.
Now with regards to gay marriage
specifically,
that's a really tough one for me
because,
you know,
I can imagine
I can't do anything really other than
spout platitudes about it.
I suppose unfortunately,
you know,
is if the marital vows are taken
seriously,
then it seems to me that it's a means
whereby gay people can be integrated
more thoroughly and to standard society
and that's probably a good thing and
maybe that would decrease promiscuity,
which is a public health problem.
Um,
although obviously that's not limited to
gay people.
Um,
although gay men tend to be more
promiscuous than average,
probably because there's no women to
bind them with regards to their sexual
activity.
The problem is,
is that it does seem to me to be part of
a wedge and it isn't obvious to me that,
that legalizing gay marriage has done
anything to decrease the demands that
the radical left neo marxists types are
placing on traditional society.
So,
um,
those are my views.
I know they're confused,
you know,
because I'm in favor of extending the
bounds of traditional relationships to
people who wouldn't be involved in a
traditional longterm relationship.
But I'm concerned about the undermining
of,
of traditional modes of being,
including marriage,
which is technically and historically
been a union between a man and a woman.
Fundamentally,
the purpose of raising children in a,
in a stable and,
and,
uh,
um,
an optimal and stable environment.
So,
and marriage has already taken a fair
bit of damage over the last few decades.
You know,
poor people are increasingly less likely
to be married and that's really not good
for them as far as I'm concerned.
Hi,
I'm currently going through a hard time
as a first time mum with a nine month
old.
I feel depressed and anxious and I'm
highly neurotic and volatile.
Can you suggest anything to help me be a
better mom?
Well,
you know,
lots of people have a hard time with.
They're nine months old.
I guess the first question would be,
are you getting enough sleep?
Do you have enough help?
Are you eating enough?
Especially in the morning,
you know,
and you're gonna feel highly neurotic
and volatile to some degree because
while you've been through quite a
physiological trauma and it's very
demanding to have a newborn baby.
So the best thing I could say,
not knowing you,
is to make sure that you have people
around that you can talk to about your
baby and that you can and,
and that you can take a break when you
need to and have someone spell you.
I mean that's often the role that a
husband plays in the first year of,
of a baby's life,
is that he can,
he's supposed to watch the mother to
make sure that she doesn't get
overwhelmed by the demands of the baby.
And so I would hope that you're able to
ask for support when you need it and not
to be afraid of asking for support,
especially to get a rest and to get
something to eat because that's really
important,
especially in the morning.
Other than that,
I can't tell you anything really
specific unfortunately,
given that I don't know anything about
the specifics of your situation.
Um,
if it gets out of hand,
you know,
you should go.
The other thing I should say as if it
gets out of hand,
you should go speak with your,
with your doctor,
with a professional,
because you might have postpartum
depression.
There's some dispute about whether that
exists and as an independent diagnostic
entity,
but you can certainly be physiologically
stressed and if you have a
predisposition to depression then that
kind of physiological stress and sleep
disruption can bring it on.
So I would say if it really gets out of
hand,
don't hesitate to go talk to someone
professional.
You know,
it,
it's,
it may be necessary to do that because
you don't want to fall too far down a
whole,
that's for sure.
So
Emma Joe Lovano,
vic says,
Dr Peterson,
I want to thank you.
I guess this isn't a question for what
you do.
I'm a 22 year old girl and your videos
are helping me so much with figuring my
life out.
You are alone are helping me be braver
everyday.
Well,
I'm really happy about that.
You know,
and I like your emphasis on bravery,
you know,
because one of the things that we've
learned as clinicians say is that when
you help people overcome anxiety,
it isn't that you make them less anxious
necessarily.
Although I think you could do that to
some degree by having people confront
some of the demons in their past,
but instead of making them less anxious,
you make them braver and that's not the
same thing.
Right?
Because there's lots of reason to be
anxious.
The world's full of uncertainty and fear
and reasons for fear and reasons for
pain,
but to be braver means to confront those
voluntarily and that's really a good
thing.
When will the next Bible lecture
occurred?
October 24th.
They'll be three of them before the end
of December and I want to keep them
going into the future.
They,
they've been quite successful I would
say,
and I would like to go through the whole
book,
although that would probably take me the
rest of my life,
but I do really think it's necessary
because it is the case that the.
The specific narratives and the
metanarrative that are,
that are embedded in the biblical
stories and its surrounding literature
are at the fundament of Western culture
and we need to reconnect with that in
order to make sure that our,
that our culture stays strong and I
don't think it's particularly strong
right now and that's a very bad.
That's a very bad thing for everyone.
It leads to nihilism and despair and and
in an ability to plan for a meaningful
future and cynicism and all of those
things,
and that's especially bad for young
people because when you're young and
your life is ahead of you,
it's the last.
It's the last time that you need to be
nihilistic and cynical.
It's definitely not good.
So
Shark Pyre to says,
how can you dispute the theory that
Jesus is just a rewrite of the Sun God
myth?
Well,
I wouldn't necessarily dispute that
theory,
although I would dispute the just.
I mean the strange things about the
biblical stories and let's say about the
new testament stories,
is that they echo across multiple levels
of analysis and so there is an
astrological element to the Christ.
A story,
um,
that you wrote about a fair bit in a
book called Ion,
which is a very terrifying book and
there are echoes of the myths of the
sudden God.
And,
but the funny thing is,
and this is one of the things I can't
really understand about the biblical
stories,
is that they manifest themselves at
multiple levels of interpretation
simultaneously.
And you could say that that's merely a
consequence of continual historical
reworking.
And I suppose that could be the case,
but the fact that they manifest
themselves as a personal story and as a
cosmic story and as a historical story
and as a mythological story and that it
all works at the same time strikes me
as,
as pointing to something that's really
somewhat beyond our current level of
understanding.
I can't elaborate on that a lot because
it would take us into places that I
really would rather not go.
But I do believe that there's something
synchronous using young's terminology
about,
uh,
about a death and resurrection story.
And the synchronous element is,
is associated with the fact that the
story echoes across so many levels of
analysis.
And my sense is that when something
echoes across many levels of analysis,
that means that it's approaching
something like a very deep truth.
So I know that isn't normally how we go
about determining what constitutes
truth,
but we don't know everything about how
to determine what constitutes truth yet.
And there are many things that we have
yet to figure out and that's certainly
one of them as far as I'm concerned.
So there is a Sungard myth element,
certainly parallels between Christ and
horace,
for example.
But
that doesn't mean you can just say it's
just a rewrite.
I don't think that the,
I don't think that that's historically
or a psychologically accurate.
Have you watched rick and morty?
No,
I haven't.
Many people have told me to watch rick
and Morty,
although they said it's very dark and.
Well that doesn't bother me so much I
suppose,
although I'm plenty dark perhaps without
adding to it.
So.
But um,
I would like to watch it and I probably
will.
So I would love for you to do come and
do a talk in Montreal.
Well,
you never know that might happen.
I've been talking to Gad Saad about that
a fair bit,
you know,
he's coming to Toronto November 11th so
we can do the talk.
That was shut down by Ryerson back in
August,
so I'm looking forward to that.
So
what's the best way to stop drinking
alcohol and start doing my best?
In my psychology degree,
it's affecting my study,
but I can do very well if I stop.
I'm 26.
Well,
Paul,
what I would say is I think you should
do the future authoring program and you
should really concentrate.
There's a section in it that helps you
determine what your positive view of
your future would be,
but another section that helps you
determine what would happen in your life
if you're negative habits got out of
control and one of the things that can
really help you control your alcohol
intake is to really,
really think through what you're giving
up and where you could be in five years
if you don't get it under control and
proclivity to alcoholism can be a really
vicious thing.
You know,
lots of people get dragged down into the
mud by alcohol,
excessive alcohol intake,
especially if they're sensitive to the
opiate response that alcohol can
produce.
And you can tell that if you,
when you drink,
you know,
you get alert and,
and,
uh,
let's say more enthusiastic and
energetic and then you don't want to
stop drinking.
That's uh,
that's definitely a bad sign with
regards to developing alcoholism.
So I would say you need to figure out
something that's,
that's more important to you that
drinking and also think through very
hard.
The negative consequences of continuing
your.
You're at about the age 26 where you
should stop.
I mean guys who are going to stop
generally start slow down pretty,
pretty intensely around that age.
Um,
you know,
get also treating your psychology,
studying as a fulltime job can also be
helpful.
So,
you know,
get up at eight morning or 7:30 in the
morning and start hitting the books by
nine and put in a 68 hour day.
And then even if you do keep drinking,
at least you're moving forward.
So that's what I say about that.
Are you a science fiction fan?
You referenced timelines,
starship troopers in lecture,
and your ideas often remind me of Harry
Selden's plan from Asia mobs foundation
series.
Hey,
well,
when I was a kid,
which is quite a long time ago now,
um,
I lived in this town called Fairview
Alberta,
which was a town of about 3000 people a
way the hell north 350 miles northwest
of Edmonton.
And I have this neighbor across the
street across the La actually.
And he had a huge science fiction
library.
It must've been,
I don't know,
5,000 books there,
19 seventies,
1960,
19 seventies classics like Heinlein
then.
And how's it Marvin?
He would let me go over there and take
like 20 books at a time and I was
reading about a book a day at that point
and I read science fiction like mad
probably till I was about 19 or so and
maybe a little younger than that.
And then turn more to classic literature
when I got to college.
And,
and,
uh,
also partly as a consequence of some
lessons that the local librarian taught
me about what to read.
So I was a science fiction fan.
I haven't read science fiction for a
very long time,
although I was pretty happy with it when
I was a kid.
So
Richard Vanc carpet and says,
yes,
I have,
I phobia.
And would love to hear about anxiety.
Well that's a,
that's a rough thing to have
agoraphobic.
So agoraphobic,
get increasingly isolated and afraid of
things outside of their domain and
familiarity.
And often what happens with agora phobia
is that people who develop it or afraid
of two things,
they're afraid that something is going
to go dreadfully wrong with their
health,
especially with regards to their hearts.
So they start to become afraid that
maybe they'll have a heart attack and
that they'll die in public,
far from a hospital and that don't make
a fool of themselves while they're doing
it or well,
they,
well,
they think they're done.
So it's a combination of two fears and
one is fear of mortality.
And the other is fear of social
judgement.
And you might think about those as the
two main categories of feared that
possessed people because one is
associated obviously with mortality and
death and the other is associated with
exclusion from the group,
which of course can lead to mortality
and death.
And so the agoraphobic skip the worst of
both worlds.
And it's often a disease of middle aged
women,
but not always.
And there are often people who've been
somewhat dependent in their previous
lives and then undergo some traumatic
event like a divorce or the death.
Someone close and at the same time are
perhaps experiencing heart palpitations
that are associated with menopause that
brings ideas of mortality to mind.
And that can trigger a panic attack,
which is a very,
um,
what would you call it,
unpleasant experience to say the least.
Um,
and then that fear of panic attack
starts making people avoid.
And that's when Agora Phobia develops
out of anxiety disorders with panic
attacks.
So you go out and maybe you go to a mall
and maybe you're in a crowd and maybe
you start thinking about,
well,
your heartbeat and about the fact that
someone close to you has died and maybe
then you become aware of your heartbeat
and you start to panic because you feel
that maybe it's the beat is irregular or
or that or that.
You can't detect it as well as you
usually can.
And then that makes your heart
accelerate because it makes you afraid.
And then you get more more.
What would you call sensitive to that
and that makes your heart rate beat even
faster.
And then you panic.
You want to get to the hospital to get
checked out to make sure that you're all
right and then you make your fatal
mistake,
which is that you avoid going back to
the mall and then you go to a grocery
store and the same thing happens and
then you start to avoid going to the
grocery store.
Then you start to avoid avoiding the
subway or taxis or crowds or anywhere
you might get trapped and wouldn't be
able to get to the hospital.
Soon you end up avoiding everything and
that's when your life really starts to
become a living hell.
So the basic way to treat or a phobia.
There's two ways.
One is to develop some control of
breathing,
to do progressive relaxation,
and the way you do that is that you
start with your start by concentrating
on your toes and your feet and your
ankles and your shins,
your knees.
You move all the way up your body and
let the tension flow out of your muscles
and regulate your breathing calmly and
carefully so that you can learn to relax
and then you go out.
You go out voluntarily am start to
confront the things you're afraid of.
So for example,
if you're afraid of the mall,
maybe you go to the parking lot and you
look at them all and then you walk close
to the door and you look inside,
you know,
and then you go home because that's
enough for one day.
But you do progressive exposure.
And that's the base,
one of the basic rules of psychotherapy
is that if you're afraid of something,
you progressively and voluntarily expose
yourself to it,
and that generally it's the voluntary
exposure that's curative,
right?
Accidental exposure could make you
worse,
but voluntary exposure can be curative
and that's sort of associated with the
myth of the hero and the Dragon.
You know the hero is the person who goes
out voluntarily to confront the dragon
and overcome it and get the treasure.
And so if you voluntarily expose
yourself to things you're afraid of,
like no more than you can tolerate,
then you'll find that you get braver and
you learned that you can tolerate the
fear and that can chase the agora phobia
back,
but it's very important to do it on a
regular basis.
And if you agoraphobic full fledged,
agoraphobic and should probably consult
professional help because it's very
tricky condition and it can be very,
can really impair you badly.
So that's what I would recommend.
Hi Jp.
I'm wondering how the computer program
that rates university courses as
worthwhile or not is coming along well.
It isn't rating them as worthwhile.
It's rating the mess postmodern Neil
Marxist or not and it's actually fully
developed.
I was going to launch it and I didn't.
I didn't design it a,
somebody volunteered to design it and
presented it to me and it seems to work
very well.
Um,
I was going to launch it at the end of
August so that this year is university
students could benefit from it,
but there was the Charlottesville event
and then I got busy and I also wasn't
feeling great and so I just didn't hit
the window of time properly.
But I hope to be able to launch it for
the January incoming class to do a video
about what's wrong with the university
system.
That many things that are wrong with the
university system and to launch the
website.
At the same time.
I also had people suggest to me that
maybe it wasn't a good idea that it
would increase polarization,
but I've thought about that for about a
month and a half.
And I think that the benefit to the
consumer.
So that would be the informed student
outweighs any danger of polarization.
And besides that,
something has to be done because the
situation in the universities is really
ridiculous.
So.
All right,
so let's see what else we've got here in
the chat room.
Dvs S,
k e r three.
That's quite a mouthful.
Says I'm studying to be a teacher,
but I'm also an introvert.
Could this be a big problem?
Can I still be a successful teacher?
Actually,
what seems to predict success at
teaching best is intelligence and
conscientiousness.
That's the data so far.
So if you're conscientious,
then you'll probably be fine.
I mean extra introverts have a harder
time speaking in front of groups,
but you can learn to do that.
You know,
an introvert can become a very
successful public speaker.
May Not enjoy it the same way that an
extrovert might.
But that doesn't mean that you can't
learn the skills.
And what I would recommend for an
introvert is the same thing that I do
when I'm lecturing is I never talked to
the whole group.
You know,
it doesn't matter how big the crowd is,
I'm always picking out individuals in
the group and talking specifically to
them.
So I'll make a point to an individual
and I watched their face and see if
they're nodding and understanding,
right,
because that way you make contact with
the entire audience and then,
you know,
we'll all talk to someone for about 15
seconds or so.
I don't want to put them on the spot too
much and then I shift my attention to
someone else and I sort of pin point
around the room and that keeps everybody
in the room focused on what I'm saying
because each person reflects the entire
crowd back to you.
And so I would say if you're an
introvert or if you want to speak in
public in general,
forget about the damn crowd.
It doesn't exist.
Speak to people one on one at a time and
an introvert can do that just fine.
So you know,
that's where your strengths would be.
I would say you're,
you're much more likely to be
unsuccessful as a teacher if you don't
work hard at it.
And if you're not interested in it.
So if you're an introvert,
I wouldn't worry about that.
I don't think that that'll be the
biggest problem that you'll face.
So
sure.
Nick's are overrated.
Says ditch your barber,
like my barber quite a bit to hit his
haircuts a little shorter than I'm
accustomed to and there's some reasons
for that.
But uh,
um.
Oh,
what can I say?
How hair grows back and it will be just
as beautiful as I was before.
No time.
So I guess that's how that.
See now Richard Van Copeland says my
haircuts looking fresh.
So who's that?
Nick's are overrated.
Take the APP.
Yeah.
So,
um,
would you consider having a discussion
with Thomas Soul that Sam,
dogen,
dogen probably.
Oh yeah,
I definitely considered it.
I'm thinking hard about reaching out to
him.
I have some discussions coming up that
you might be interested in.
So I'm going to talk on Jocko willink
podcast and he was the leader of the
Navy seals team in Ramadan and he's
quite the tough character.
I met him down in San Diego a while
back,
a month ago or so,
and that was very interesting.
I have a video already prepared that's
an interview with our out in hers,
the elite,
um,
it was done by skype and needs some
editing and so that's been a bit
delayed.
I interviewed or discussed,
I had a discussion with Nina Paley who
was a great animator.
You guys should look her up.
That's Nina Paley.
She animated a lot of the Old Testament
and set it to music and I think your
animations are unbelievably beautiful.
And the meeting,
she has great musical tastes.
They're illegal videos.
Basically she's making an illegal movie.
Um,
but anyways,
I really liked your stuff.
I also had a discussion with Claire
Lehmann who runs quill at,
which is a new newsmagazine online,
which I think has got real promise and
we had a good discussion and um,
let's see.
Is that helped?
I think that's it on and you probably
know or maybe you don't.
Um,
I just finished a discussion with
Camille Paglia and we went down there.
I took a film crew down there to
Philadelphia and met her at her
university and we talked for a couple of
hours and that was really interesting.
She's quite the fireball,
that woman and unbelievably verbally
fluent and sharp.
And so I finally met someone who could
more than me and,
and uh,
that's probably good.
So,
but I really enjoyed speaking with her
and I think about 100,000 people have
watched that now in a day,
so that's pretty good.
So we talked about postmodernism and the
malaise that confronts the modern
university and all of those sorts of
things.
So Robin Deon says,
do you ever Miss Montreal?
Hey,
I was just in Montreal.
I went there to saw,
saw a band called half moon run,
which are abandoned.
I would highly recommend they were
playing with the Montreal Symphony
Orchestra and I got invited to meet one
of the singers and also go in and see
the concert,
which was excellent.
And Yeah,
I'd Miss Montreal.
Montreal is a great city for you.
Americans who are listening should go
visit Montreal.
Man.
It's a cool place and spend a week there
in the summer.
It's,
it's a really good city in every way.
So
yeah.
it seems we are bound to repeat history
and what his old becomes new again.
Why is it that we can't seem to find
equilibrium within a society?
Ideas begin with good intentions,
but lead towards the extreme.
Yeah.
Well,
the reason we can't find equilibrium is
because the environment that we live in
isn't an equilibrium,
and so I.
I kind of imagine it this way.
It's like we're,
we're traversing the back of a giant.
This is obviously a symbolic reference
of the giant serpent and it's and it
weaves back and forth and you don't know
at any moment which way it's going to
curve and turn.
And so sometimes it turns to the right
and sometimes it turns to the left.
And what that means politically is that
sometime we have to turn to the right
and sometimes we have to turn to the
left and we don't know exactly when
those,
what you call,
we don't know exactly how to time that.
And so what we all have to do is keep
our eyes open and tell the truth and
discuss things with each other,
especially with people who have
political beliefs that are different
than us so that we can ensure that we
haven't tilted too far.
One way or the other,
and that's why I'm an advocate of free
speech or one of the many reasons I'm an
advocate of free speech is because it's
the continual dialogue between people of
different temperamental types that keeps
us oriented as close as we can to the
center of the serpents back.
And so there is no permanent
equilibrium.
There's only the equilibrium that's
produced by continual negotiation and a
democracy is a formalized negotiation.
And so,
um,
and,
and it's free speech that keeps it
healthy and alive.
So there's no permanent equivalent
equilibrium state except death.
And it's always negotiation in
relationships too,
like if you have an intimate
relationship or a familial relationship
or even a friendship,
there's no final equilibrium state.
You have to communicate with each other
honestly all the time and keep the
relationship moving to adjust the
environment that the relationship is
operating in.
That's how it stays alive.
And in an intimate,
longterm intimate relationship like a,
it's a continual,
uh,
it takes continual effort.
I mean,
it's worthwhile effort and that,
but you have to be conscious and awake
to keep your relationship alive and you
have to be communicating all the time.
Well,
maybe not all the time because you can
overcommunicate too,
but I'm so well,
so that's why we can't reach a state of
permanent equilibrium.
Okay.
Let's go back to the previously
submitted questions.
How can I overcome my fear of driving on
freeways?
Well,
one of the things you could do,
this is Ellis,
is do a fair bit of imagining driving on
freeways and try to make the imagining
as realistic as possible,
but then the other thing you can do is,
again,
it's graduated exposure.
If you're afraid of driving,
go drive with someone you trust in a
parking lot on Sunday morning when
there's no one there and then drive
around the block and the street that
isn't busy and then go to a slightly
busier street and then go to the
slightly busier street and then find a
highway that's like a,
just a two layer so that you know,
you could practice merging and that sort
of thing.
And you've got to build a plan,
say with 20 degrees of difficulty with
the highest degree of difficulty,
maybe being more merging onto a busy
four lane highway and you can go at
night and practice merging onto the busy
highway because they won't be busy at
night.
So I would say what you do is you break
it down into small steps and then
practice each step until you're bored
with the step and when you're bored with
it,
that means you're no longer anxious
about it and don't quit,
you know,
like stick at it because it's really
useful to overcome a fear.
And once you've identified it,
fear,
then you've identified something to
overcome that can definitely make you
stronger.
So like good luck with it and get
professional.
Like take a driving course if you need
to as well and find someone to work
with.
It isn't going to make you nervous and
isn't going to harass you,
but don't quit.
It's really important to overcome a fear
like that.
No,
I just picked something I shouldn't have
clicked.
Actually.
I'm pretty happy with myself.
My son isn't here.
As I mentioned,
I'm still not like destroying this
completely,
although I may have done it now.
No.
Hmm.
See that's what happens when you brag
because now all I've got is one question
from pigeon hole and not all of them.
Let's see.
Got It.
Back to chart
was the trick.
So Hey,
I'm,
I'm actually managing this up too badly.
So let's see here.
Some more questions from the,
from the Youtube people,
Dr Peterson.
I'm really hoping you can share your
thoughts on the daigous shooting.
Yeah.
Well,
what I would do is recommend the
biblical lecture I did on Cain and Abel
would say because I think that that's a
good summary of the state of mind that
somebody has to be in in order to do
what was done at Los Vegas.
So you have to be very,
very embittered by lights in order to do
that sort of thing and you have to be
searching for revenge,
I would say.
And it's not,
you know,
you might think,
well it's only revenge on other people
because you've developed hatred for
people,
but it's deeper than that.
It's not just hatred for people.
I would say it's hatred for being itself
and and the desire to take revenge on
being for the outrage of the tragedy and
suffering that's associated with being
and maybe the tragedy and suffering
that's been part and parcel of your own
life and that makes you embittered and
then past embittered becomes outraged
and past outraged becomes well homicidal
or even genocidal and that's terrible
state of mind to be in.
It's a hellish state.
Well,
I believe that the best way to
conceptualize the state of mind that
someone has to be in in order to do
something like the columbine shootings
for example,
or what happened in Las Vegas is that
you're really an now you have to speak
about it.
Religious languages,
you're really out for revenge against
God for the outrage of creation.
That's what it looks like to me and
that's a state of mind that's truly
hellish and you could get there by
broody long enough.
Now it's also possible.
I mean this guy didn't have any previous
history,
criminal history or anything like that
and he's pretty old.
So you know,
there's also also also the possibility
of some kind of neurological pathway log
that that might be characteristic of
him,
you know,
some degenerative neurological disease.
There was a kid years ago at the
University of Texas at Austin who
climbed up on the tower there and shot a
number of people with a high powered
rifle and he had a fast growing tumor on
his hypothalamus and had reported like
these being overcome with extreme
feelings of rage.
And so that's another possibility.
But I would say the embitterment
hypothesis is the strongest one.
I would also say too,
I noticed the Steven Pinker tweeted this
today,
is that one of the ways of controlling
this sort of thing would be for the
press to agree not for there to be a
blanket agreement,
not to publicize the name or any other
identity markers of the people who do
the shooting.
Because there's also this
really,
what would you call it,
arrogance.
It's a kind of arrogance and pride last
ditch,
arrogance and pride that that is
associated with the fantasies that drive
this sort of behavior.
And the fantasy is something like,
well,
after I do this,
everyone will know the who,
who the hell I was,
you know,
even though maybe I was ignored or
unhappy when I was alive after I'm dead,
everybody's going to know who I was and
what I did and you know,
so there's this underground desire for
fame,
I guess it's notoriety,
but notoriety might be preferable to
being ignored.
And so,
you know,
there's a lot of talk about gun control
and that's understandable,
especially with regards to automatic
rifles.
Although I also understand why the
people who are gun owners are afraid of,
of,
of allowing what they regard as one of
their fundamental rights to be infringed
upon.
Um,
but it would certainly be useful if we
stopped giving people who do this sort
of thing now,
$100,000,000 worth of free publicity and
all the notoriety they can manage.
So,
you know,
that's another way of thinking about
controlling it.
So,
and Tony was.
Sylvia says,
you need a break,
have a glass of wine.
Relax.
Yeah.
Well,
I was just up.
I have this little cabin up north of
Toronto,
about three hours north that my wife
bought with some money that her dad left
her,
gave her.
Actually,
he's still alive and I was up there this
weekend and it was relaxing.
I was working a bit on this new
personality scale and on the video,
but I did relax a bit and I'm actually
feeling a lot better than it was for the
last and a so the mornings are still
rough,
but by this time of night I'm feeling
vaguely human,
so thank God for that because it was
pretty brutal.
So anyhow,
Franklin says,
fans are cancer for the authentic
individual.
Well,
that's a tough one.
You know,
I mean,
cancer know that.
That's too,
that's too dramatic.
I mean,
I guess that what you're pointing out is
the danger of fame and I can certainly
appreciate that.
I can't say that I'm particularly
comfortable with it,
which might seem to be rather
hypocritical as it isn't.
Like I've shied away from exposing my
views in public,
but I felt that I was driven to that by
necessity and also by my desire to
educate people.
Um,
however,
I would say despite the fact that I'm
somewhat uncomfortable with it,
I think that's mostly because of the
responsibility,
you know,
what I've been terrified for a whole
year that I say something,
you know,
unforgivably stupid and
demolished myself in public and you
don't feel guilty and horrible about
that for the rest of my life.
And so far I'd be fortunate there's been
some close calls,
but I've been fortunate,
but,
you know,
now when I go places,
people often recognize me.
Even at this little town we went up to
this weekend,
there were two people that came up to me
in the parking lot and we're excited to
meet the and you know,
the vast majority of encounters,
all of the encounters that I have with
people in public and have been really
wonderful.
I have to say that the people have been
extremely friendly and you know,
sometimes they're a bit star struck,
which I find strange.
I can see the projection,
you know,
so it's,
it's unsettling for me,
although I'm not judging anybody for it.
It's just a strange thing to observe.
Um,
but,
you know,
I can't complain about the fact that
people are,
are,
uh,
are positively predisposed to what I'm
doing.
I mean,
it's such a privilege.
I can't imagine what it would be like to
be hated publicly.
I think that would just kill me.
I really think that.
But um,
so I mean it's,
it's,
I suppose there's the possibility of
having that sort of thing go to your
head and it's,
it,
I mean that happens to people,
but I think I've said this before,
maybe on the q and a's I have a pretty
sensible family and I have a pretty.
Um,
what would you say?
I have a pretty good sense of my
limitations.
I would say,
um,
let's,
we could even call it an acute sense and
so I'm not particularly worried that
this is going to go to my head in some
way that,
that would
no
inflate my ego or something like that.
Huh?
I mean,
I think one of the things I have noticed
is that I might be a little less patient
with people when I'm speaking.
I'm because I'm more used to that,
more used to that might be good for me
to be listened to and so I have to watch
that,
but I'm pretty,
I've always been pretty noisy and
talkative and so that's probably
something that's plagued me or being a
characteristic of me ever since I was a
little tiny kid.
I mean,
I used to talk all the time when I was a
little little,
little guy.
I mean,
I think my cousin Eric Bonus,
he probably listens to this.
He used to call me motor mouth and that
was about exactly right.
I was like a miniature Camille Paglia.
So,
um,
anyways,
I can't complain about having let's say,
fans.
So people have been unbelievably good to
me and I'm really grateful for that.
So
what is the best way to find a routine
when you're diagnosed?
Bipolar?
Well,
I would say a couple of things.
The first is try to set your sleep wake
cycle stabling,
so pick a time in the morning to get up.
That's the most important thing is get
up at the same time every morning and
that that might be difficult both when
you're mad mannequin when you're
depressed,
but the closer you can stick to that,
the better.
And I would also say try to stabilize
when you go to bed and maybe a little
later rather than a little earlier
because you don't want to be laying
there flipping around like a,
like a fish trying to go to sleep.
Um,
you want to stabilize your sleep wake
routines because bipolar disorder is in
part a circadian rhythm disorder.
And so anything that destabilizes your
secret and rhythms is going to increase
the probability that you'll have an
episode.
And that includes flying.
I do believe that at Gatwick airport
there's,
in England,
there's a special team that deals with
people whose main mainly has been
triggered by the overnight flight.
So,
and then the other thing I would say is
stabilized the times you eat because
these basic biological rhythms,
eating and sleeping in particular are
part of what stabilize your nervous
system.
And if you have bipolar disorder,
then you're likely to be
very susceptible to destabilize,
destabilize routine,
routinized activities,
routinize your life to the degree that
that's possible.
And I would say the other thing you
could do is use a calendar,
you know,
and like a Google calendar or whatever,
whatever calendar.
And I would say that's a good thing for
everyone who's listening to think about
so one to plan out your days and your
weeks and you don't plan to prison,
right?
You use the calendar to design the days
that you would like to have.
And so part of that is going to be
responsibility obviously because you
have to keep up with your
responsibilities or they overwhelm you
and they multiply like hydrus and.
But you need to plan for things that you
really want to do as well.
And the calendar can really be your
friend.
And I would say of all the things that
you can do to organize yourself and
routinize yourself.
Learning to use a calendar is probably
among the foremost.
And it doesn't matter if it takes you a
year to get good at it.
You know what I mean?
You've got the rest of your life then to
benefit from that.
And you should make friends with the
calendar.
Like I said,
I don't treat it like a prison,
but it's really important to,
to,
um,
stabilize yourself as much as possible.
So
periphery Pete says,
I fell asleep listening to you.
My battery died.
I got to change it.
All right.
It looks like everything is okay.
Again,
I use it a reflex camera my and um,
it has a battery.
No electrical plugins.
So I'm afraid I'm at the mercy of its
batteries,
the very high quality camera though.
So I think it's worth,
worth the trouble.
Anyways,
periphery Pete said I fell asleep
listening to you,
which,
you know,
that doesn't sound so good.
So that part's not so good.
But this part is good.
The next day my 60 filter less
cigarettes a day habit disappeared.
Not sure what you said,
but thank you Claire X.
Hey.
Well,
if you can figure out what you were
listening to,
um,
maybe I can make a tape of things to
listen to by Jordan Peterson while
you're falling asleep to fix your
cigarette habit.
But anyways,
I think that's great.
Don't,
don't start again.
Or if you do,
make sure you quit.
Again.
I'm really glad to hear that and I've
never had that particular talent pointed
out to me before.
So that's pretty interesting and
comical.
So
do you believe there's a strong
undercurrent of gnosticism in our
country?
GNOSTICISM,
by the way,
is the doctrine heretical doctrine from
a classical Christian perspective that
you can attain religious insight through
understanding that's an oversimplified
view,
but um,
things like the sacred feminine and
hatred of the created world.
God,
that's a complicated question.
I think there's an undercurrent of
wanting to be gnosticism in our country.
You know,
I think that people believe they can
come to religious enlightenment through
understanding,
but that they are generally less willing
to do the work that would be necessary
to do that.
Then then is in fact necessary.
It takes an awful lot of study,
like it took me years of reading young
to really start to understand what he
was talking about.
10,
you know,
you could think about young as a
gnostic,
but most people who talk about young
haven't read anything he wrote.
While that's true,
often of things that people talk about
in general,
but I mean I think there is a place for
understanding and religious belief or
other.
Otherwise I wouldn't be doing this
biblical lecture series,
but I think it's pseudo gnosticism
fundamentally and it's people putting
forward ill considered opinions in the
place of solid religious,
symbolic doctrine and I think that's a
big problem.
I think it's part of what makes us weak
and I think we are at the moment week in
our foundations as a civilization,
so
I have trouble regulating my emotions.
I have a suspicion it's to do with the
fact that I'm 90 percentile and
openness,
conscientiousness and neuroticism and
second percentile in agreeableness and
extroversion.
Any tips on dealing with that?
Yeah,
well,
if you're really high in openness and
you're really high in neuroticism,
that can be a rough combination.
The conscientious news should actually
help with that,
although it might make you a bit
perfectionistic.
Um,
the problem with being high in openness,
which is creativity and interest in
ideas and high in neuroticism,
which is tendency towards anxiety and
emotional pain,
is that like open people like to break
open boxes,
conceptual boxes,
and see what's inside,
like Pandora's box,
but people are high in neuroticism or
are more likely to respond negatively to
complexity and uncertainty.
And if you're an open person and you're
always thinking of new things,
you,
you tend to,
um,
saw off the branch that you're sitting
on on a regular basis.
And that can be pretty destabilizing.
Any tips on dealing with that?
Well,
I would repeat what I said earlier.
I think that one of the things that you
do if you're high in anxiety,
is to stabilize your sleep wake cycles.
So get up at the same time.
Go to bed at the same time and eat at
the same time.
Make sure that you eat breakfast and a
big breakfast too.
That's heavy on fat and protein because
if you're hungry and then you stress
yourself,
especially if you're high in
neuroticism,
you destabilize your,
your insulin production system and it
will restabilize till you go to sleep
again.
So I would say like two things.
One is have a big breakfast and then
also if you're feeling particularly
anxious,
try eating something,
not carbohydrates and see if that helps
because you,
you might be somewhat permanently
dysregulated in your insulin,
stress-related insulin production.
That would be worth trying.
I would also say that you should shield
yourself to some degree from news
sources and sources of bad news,
especially,
um,
catastrophic news because most of it
isn't news.
It's the repetition of things that we
already know full well and there's
reason to protect yourself from an
onslaught of negative information,
especially when it's not really
necessary for you.
I mean,
I don't think you should bury your head
in the sand,
but constant exposure to the
catastrophes of the world,
especially when there's nothing you can
do about those catastrophes even
hypothetically,
is something that can really destabilize
people.
I often tell people in my clinical
practice,
um,
which isn't operating right now by the
way,
to shield themselves from news reports
because it's too much.
If you're depressed and anxious,
it's just not something that you need.
It's not helpful to you second
percentile in agreeableness and
extroversion.
Well,
you know,
one of the things that you can do if
you're that low in agreeableness that
shouldn't disregulate your emotions,
but it might interfere with your
relationships with other people you
know,
because you might be a little bit harder
to.
You might take other people's feelings
into consideration less than might be
good for you.
One of the things that people who are
low in agreeableness can do is to try to
think of things they could do for other
people and make that a practice.
You know,
like maybe once a week you could
consciously do someone a favor or give
someone a gift,
something like that.
And practice being,
um,
what would you call it?
Compassionate and polite,
you know,
that'll expand your personality rather
than transforming it.
So then maybe you could have the
advantages of being disagreeable,
which means you're tough minded.
And skeptical and competitive and and
those can all be really good things,
but it would be nice to be able to leave
it out a little bit with some with the
ability to take other people's
perspectives a bit more and to take them
into account.
And then you know,
if your relationships improve,
that can also improve your emotional
stability because one of the ways that
people regulate their anxiety is by
having people around them that they get
along with because you know,
if you're upset people then they upset
you and especially if you're high in
neuroticism and that can increase your
anxiety and your pain.
So
Mr David says,
should I hide my antifeminist
anti-feminism I presume as I studied
university to become a nurse?
Well
look,
you shouldn't make unnecessary enemies
and you probably shouldn't mouth your
opinion more than necessary,
but I think you risk damaging your soul
under certain circumstances when you
don't say what you think.
So I wouldn't hide it because I think
it's dangerous to hide it.
And you also won't find out,
find the other people that you listened
to,
but I would say be prudent.
You know,
um,
don't falsify your opinions when you're
writing.
That's a big mistake.
Don't falsify your opinions when you're
speaking.
You can always choose not to speak,
you know,
but if you feel that you would be doing
damage to your integrity,
then you have to say what you have to
say.
Do it carefully and,
and prepare for the consequences,
you know,
uh,
probably prepare beforehand I would say.
So I think the hiding is a bad idea,
like I said,
but don't make unnecessary enemies,
you know,
because there's just no utility in that.
How important do you believe the
American right?
Is the American right to bear arms and
maintain malicious?
Is it equivalent to the right to free
speech?
Well,
I don't think anything is equivalent to
the right to free speech or the
responsibility for free speech.
Um,
how important do I believe that?
That right is Jesus?
That's a tough question.
You know,
my dad's a hunter,
he has 200 rifles,
something like that.
They're all single shots because he
believes the naming carefully.
Um,
the culture I come from,
which is northwestern Canada,
is a rural culture,
a hunting culture.
People take their guns seriously there
and it is definitely part of their
lifestyle.
I mean,
my dad hunted his whole life and we ate
wild meat almost all the time I was
growing up.
Um,
I think that the right to bear arms is
one of the markers of a,
of a free society.
I don't think it's reasonable that only
the police and the army should be
allowed to be dangerous.
I'm having said that.
Well,
I think I'll just leave it at that.
I mean I feel obligated in some sense to
go farther,
especially with regards to what happened
in Las Vegas,
but
it seems to me that mostly what happens
after these mass shootings is that the
event gets absolutely politicized and
people take their standard positions and
there's no moving either side and that's
too bad.
But,
um,
I think that it's unfortunate to use an
event like the Las Vegas event or the
columbine shootings to make political
capital.
And I think that's usually what happens.
And so I'm not going to do that.
I think it's an important,
right.
I believe that the individual should be
allowed or even encouraged to be
dangerous,
but controlled.
No.
So along with that,
right is a responsibility and,
and I guess maybe from the NRA,
there should be more discussion of
responsibility.
Is that possible?
Now?
Seems to me to be reasonable.
So
any advice for a person with intense
chronic pain that wants to become.
Who wants to become a uh.
Oh,
sorry.
It switched on me.
Oh,
there we go.
Crayola sheep says any advice for a
person with intense chronic pain?
Who wants to become a contributing
member of society?
Specifically having the self discipline
to push through pain,
to take care of responsibilities?
Well,
the first thing I would say is that if
you have intense chronic pain,
then my heart goes out to you because
now it's really awful.
And so I think that you can cut yourself
a break.
I think the fact that you want to become
or continue being a contributing member
to society,
society is a testament to your
fortitude.
I guess the first thing I would ask you
is if your pain has been reasonably
managed,
you probably know this and I'm not
giving you any medical advice because I
can't,
but you might want to note that there
are antidepressants that are quite
effective as longterm pain medications
and you may already know that,
but if you don't,
then you should check that out because
they're not addictive and they can be a
very effective adjunct.
I would also say that the literature on
chronic pain tends to indicate that more
activity is better than less and that
and that's partly because when you get
engaged in something that's meaningful,
let's say,
and important to you,
that that activates the dopaminergic
system,
the same system that Takeda activates
and that can produce a fairly pronounced
analgesic effect.
So I would say everything that you can
do to get yourself occupied with things
that you regard as important and
worthwhile is actually probably going to
help you manage your pain better.
It looks like inactivity is a bad,
is bad.
Generally speaking for chronic pain,
I mean obviously that's not the case.
If the sort of activity that you're
engaged in is of the type that will
aggravate an underlying chronic
physiological condition,
but I would say make a plan,
make a daily plan,
make a weekly plan,
um,
make it,
you know,
push yourself a little bit farther than
you can go comfortably on a weekly basis
and see how far you can get any year.
That's because what's your choice?
I mean,
you're laying there.
Suffering is not preferable to doing
things and suffering,
not generally.
So I would say like more power to you
for trying and,
but,
but also do keep in mind that activity,
meaningful activity is a good analgesic.
So I'm Eric Butler says sheesh.
Canadians never get it.
Well,
I didn't know we get it sometimes.
Eric,
come on now,
you know,
give us a break.
We're just.
Canadians were freezing to death half
the time.
So you know,
we do pretty well given the fact that
every day here in the winter is the
equivalent of a national catastrophe in
the U.
s.
So anyways,
I'm Betsy Kirkland.
It says,
if the second amendment is taken away,
there will be nothing to protect your
freedom of speech.
That is how important.
Yes.
Well,
that is certainly the argument that
people who are
motivated to protect the second
amendment make,
and I'm not going to oppose that.
So
freedom of speech is not licensed to
bully.
Yes,
actually it is.
That is exactly what it is.
That's clique zero.
Two zero.
Three.
Freedom of speech is licensed to bullet.
It's licensed to offend.
It's licensed to disrupt.
It's all sorts of things that are
unpleasant and upsetting and um,
that doesn't mean that you should go
around bullying or being disruptive or
upsetting.
That isn't the same thing,
but that is exactly what it is.
So I'm afraid please zero to three are
wrong.
Now.
Then you say use some discretion and
thought,
well yes,
of course that's perfectly reasonable
advice and that is what people should
do.
But you know,
what constitutes discretion is often
something that has to be discussed.
And I would say that the threat to
freedom of speech is being put forward
very strongly by people who say things.
While it's not as,
it's not the same as the licensed to
bullying and bullying,
by the way generally speaking is it is a
sequence of physical auctions.
When it's verbal bullying,
which also can occur,
then that has to be put into somewhat
different category.
If you're interested in bullying,
there's a great book and seriously
interested in it.
There's a great book by a guy named Dan
always called bullying.
I think that's what it's called,
what we know and what we can do about
it.
Dan Always,
and if you know,
if you're actually concerned about that
sort of thing,
you could read that book and see if
there are places that you could put what
he advises in schools,
for example,
into practice.
So,
um,
you look young,
asked what moment triggered your
obsession with the topics outlined in
the biblical series and maps?
Well,
that's a good question.
I actually don't know the answer though.
I wouldn't say it was a moment.
I know that from the time I was about 16
until the time that I was 24.
So I had recurrent nightmares about
nuclear war.
And so that was certainly part of it and
they were very vivid and very realistic
and so and certainly my reading
especially about the Holocaust,
I'm also.
And then later Solzhenitsyn's accounts
of the Gulag archipelago,
for example,
the horrors there.
That was also a major contributor.
It was my concern about the Cold War.
I would say that was really the trigger
in general because I wanted to
understand.
I took a political science degree first
and looked at it from a political
perspective,
but most of my professors by the time I
was in my third or fourth year,
insisted that the reason that people
fought the reasons that people thought
were economic and I never did believe
that because,
well people fight about the things they
value,
but it isn't the obvious why people
value the things they value,
you know,
so it's a psychological issue as far as
I'm concerned with and not an economic
issue.
And so it was my discomfort,
dissatisfaction with the standard
political science view point directing
team point combined with this strange
obsession I had about the Cold War.
Maybe that's associated to some degree
with my proclivity to depression.
I mean,
who knows,
you know,
I don't know.
I was obsessed with it and I,
it isn't obvious why things grip you and
shake you like a rat,
you know,
I guess some,
there's something about that that seems
to be associated with people used to
call it destiny.
So,
um,
but it certainly wasn't obsession when I
was 23 or 24 when I started writing maps
of meaning I was thinking about it 16
hours a day,
like top speed,
just nonstop.
And the only relief I could get from it.
Rudy was to go work out with weights,
which I did for quite a long time.
I gained about 35 pounds in about a year
and a half working out with weights and
I had to quit because I was eating so
much.
It was taking up like half my life.
So,
um,
anyways,
I don't know what it was,
you know,
who knows,
who knows what,
what darkness lurks in the bottom of a
soul.
No one,
why it's there.
Maybe it was also the fact that I could
see in myself the tendencies that might
lead people to do terrible things and I
was also very,
very curious about that,
so maybe that was an encounter with the
union shot.
It was something like that.
Jeremy says,
will you lecture in the Netherlands?
Yes.
As a matter of fact,
I'm coming to the Netherlands in January
to lecture there.
I'll put the link to that up on my
website at some point in the relatively
near future.
So
saga strike.
I've heard depressed people who stopped
antidepressant said they never helped in
the first place.
What do you say to that,
Mr Peterson?
Hey,
that,
that certainly possible.
I'm antidepressants don't necessarily
work for everyone.
My personal opinion is that
antidepressants work quite well for many
people whose lives are in decent order,
so they have friends,
they have family that love them,
they have a career,
they're educated approximately to the
level of their intelligence.
They have things to look forward to,
but for some reason their mood is
extremely distorted.
Him and and negative and I've seen
antidepressants have miraculous effects
or people like that.
I think they're less likely to work when
people have a plethora of life problems,
which isn't exactly the same thing as
being
depressed,
you know,
like you think having a terrible life is
not the same thing as being depressed.
Although the two can overlap and it
isn't obvious to me that people who,
you know,
maybe they have a drinking problem or a
drug abuse problem,
mender unemployed and they have a
pathological family and their friends
aren't good for them and um,
you know,
they,
they have a string of failures behind
them and they don't have much to look
forward to in the future.
And all about it's,
it's a lot for an antidepressant
overcome.
But under those circumstances,
maybe the antidepressants can help stave
off feelings of like suicidal feelings
and that sort of thing.
But antidepressants don't work for
everyone,
but some people they work really well
for it.
If you're depressed,
they're definitely worth a try.
You know,
in a month if they're going to work.
Also,
there are a variety of different kinds
of antidepressants and you have to
figure out dose and you have to figure
out when you should take them during the
day and you and you have to figure out
type,
so they're,
they're not a cure,
they're a tool for helping control
negative emotion and they can be very
effective.
So,
but that doesn't mean that there aren't
people that they didn't help.
So that's what I would say about that.
What the player formerly known as most
cops says.
What do you think the role of
psychedelics will be in the future?
Marijuana will most likely be somewhat
legal everywhere in the US and this may
push someone to try stronger.
PSYCHEDELICS is this bad?
Let's start with the first one.
I have no idea what the role of
psychedelics will be in the future.
I know that the FDA just cleared ecstasy
for use for post traumatic stress
disorder,
so that's very interesting.
I know there's some very interesting
work being done at Johns Hopkins on
silicide mushrooms,
which seemed to be very effective,
for example,
in helping people stop smoking.
I think that we don't know anything
about psychedelics at all.
I mean,
we know that they seem to have an effect
on the serotonin system,
but that's a pretty broad brush stroke.
Um,
I think they are incalculably I'm
peculiar and that they reveal things
about the structure of the world that we
are beyond ignorant about,
beyond ignorant about.
I have no idea what role they'll play in
the future.
I don't know what to think about
psychedelics at all.
Um,
marijuana will most likely be somewhat
legal everywhere in the US and this may
push some to try stronger.
PSYCHEDELICS is this bad?
I suppose it depends on how they're
used,
whether or not it's bad and what the
intent is.
I think they are very bad party drugs.
Psychedelics aren't,
aren't for fun.
I don't think that that's the right way
to use them at all.
I think they need to be used seriously
and they need to be used in a manner
that's life affirming and they need to
be used in a manner that's commensurate
with genuine exploration and they need
to be used carefully or they can cause a
lot of trouble.
So Carl Jung said beware of unearned
wisdom and I think that's very wise.
So,
um,
anyways,
I hope that we continue investigating
them scientifically because there's much
to be learned there much more than we
can imagine as far as I'm concerned.
Ha [inaudible] says,
what's up with all these frog
occurrences?
I've never seen such synchronicity,
man.
I don't know what to say about that.
I had some frog synchronicity
occurrences earlier this year that just
about made me think so.
I don't know.
I have,
I have no idea what to make of it.
Um,
it leaves me speechless.
That's all I can say about that.
You know,
I,
I do get Carl young had some strange
ideas and,
and one of them was synchronicity,
you know,
the fact that things could line up in a
way that seemed meaningful and you know,
much as I don't understand how that
occurs.
I've experienced it many,
many times and it very convincing ways.
And so it's,
it's one of the things that leads me to
think that the world isn't structured
the way that we think it is.
I think it's structured more like a
symphony where where and there are times
with dis,
different parts of the world,
different parts of being could come into
harmony spontaneously and,
and all pointed in the same direction
and why that happens.
I have no idea.
All right.
I don't understand it at all.
So.
All right,
so let's go back to the preexisting
questions.
Semen.
Eric says,
apologies for the weird question.
Have you ever performed a ritual
sacrifice?
No,
I haven't and it is a weird question,
although I can understand why you would
ask it.
I have performed psychological
sacrifices,
you know,
I suppose when I decided to give up
something that I needed to give up so
that I could move forward into the
future.
Right.
That certainly happened when I quit
smoking.
When I more or less quit drinking.
I still have a drink from time to time
now,
but I quit for 20 years and that was a
sacrifice.
I couldn't continue to drink again.
I said I was from northern Alberta.
It was pretty hard drinking culture and
I really liked alcohol,
but I couldn't drink and write and do my
phd and manage my family
responsibilities.
It was too much and so I stopped and
that was a good thing.
So that was a sacrifice.
You are very critical of postmodernism,
an egalitarianism wave of the sixties.
Isn't there a danger of throwing the
baby out with the bathwater?
Are there positive things about these
movements at the moment?
No,
not really.
I don't think there's much positive
about them at all.
I think they've gone way too far.
I think they dominate the humanities.
The postmodernism mean the fact that the
postmodernist point is that there is a
very large number of ways to interpret
any closed set of phenomena,
something like that.
Any limited set of phenomena,
and that's true,
but it's,
it's shallow,
it's very,
very shallow doctrine.
And uh,
and if,
if I'm throwing the baby out with the
bathwater,
then it's a baby that needs to be thrown
out.
Afraid are the positive things about
these movements.
Not at the moment.
I can't see anything positive about it.
I think it's,
it's degenerated into ideological clap
trap and I think it's destroying the
universities.
So the egalitarian wave of the sixties,
that's a different issue I would say.
I mean at mean I don't think it's
reasonable to deny the utility of the
civil rights movement in the 19 sixties
for example.
And,
or,
and,
and you know,
there were movements before that,
like the labor movement that had real
justification for being.
It isn't that everything that always
happens on the left is bad.
I don't think that at all.
I think that the people who are,
let's say on the lower end of the
economic distribution,
need a powerful voice in politics.
Um,
I think that's only fair and I mean
there is room for an egalitarian
oriented east folks,
but that isn't what equity is.
This has become completely ideological
and there's just no,
there's just no excuse for it as far as
I'm concerned.
So,
um,
if you plan on doing meetups with more
intellectuals like Camille and Sam
Harris,
who would be your pick?
I'm,
well,
I'm going to meet Jonathan Heit.
That'll be good.
I really admire his work.
I think he's a really good guy,
so I'm looking forward to talking to
him.
I'd like to talk to Thomas Soul.
I think it's.
So I think that would be interesting.
Um,
the rest of it,
I have to think more about that.
I mean,
but those are two that I would
definitely like to talk to you.
I'm going to speak with Jocko willink.
I think I mentioned that.
So that might be interesting.
Will there be a third talk with Sam
Harris?
Maybe this time with Sam as your guests
and you taking your gloves off?
I don't have any plans for a third talk
with Sam.
I wouldn't be opposed to it,
although I think we,
I think we've probably got about as far
as we were going to get in or a second
discussion.
I think the two discussions together
actually worked quite well.
Um,
so I think,
I think,
and this is no,
I'm not saying this in any negative way,
but I think the third discussion might
be might be beating a dead horse.
I'm like,
I'm not interested in particularly in
putting Sam on the spot and you know,
and it's also possible that he would put
me on the spot.
It isn't necessarily,
but I would come out Victoria,
so to speak.
I mean he's a very sharp guy and there's
many compelling arguments to be made in
favor of atheism even though I think
that overall it's,
it's,
it's a stance lacks.
I don't think it contends with its
opponent fairly because I don't think
that the atheist community in general
takes the thought of serious religious
thinkers.
Seriously.
I think they tend to struggle
now,
but you know.
Well,
okay.
Could you please offer advice for
individuals with high intelligence but
low extroversion and low agreeableness
and making and maintaining social
connections and friendships?
Well,
I would.
That's Roger,
Roger.
I would say
make a plan.
Again,
spend some time on it weekly.
Go to things like meetups.
There's a site called meetup.com.
That's a good place to meet people.
Do whatever you have to meet people,
take a course,
strike up a conversation,
you know,
and,
and ask questions and listen that that's
particularly good.
If you're low in agreeableness,
um,
people really like to be listened to,
you know,
you don't want to pester them with
questions too badly,
but you can get an awful long ways by
listening to people and asking them
questions people hardly ever get
listened to and they're so damn help,
happy when you do it,
that,
that
they're likely to open themselves up to
you very,
very rapidly.
So get them talking and when they say
something you don't quite catch your
understand and ask them about it.
And,
and,
and that can help you move forward,
but put some time into it like you need
to be going out at least once a week,
um,
and find some social places that you can
go to regularly.
That's another thing you can do is pick
a couple of hangouts,
like a local bar or something like that
or whatever,
but go there regularly and say hi to the
people who own it and run it.
And you know,
eventually you'll be a regular and then
you can start to meet people by doing
that.
But you know,
it might take you two or three years to
get good at it.
I've seen people go to go from being
afraid to strike up a,
to have a conversation with a friend in
a,
in a coffee shop,
you know,
like have a panic attack,
thinking about that to actually doing
stand up comedy.
So you can really move yourself along
ways if you,
if you make a long time plan.
So
okay,
John Dam don't.
I've only got three dogs after that says
how should the manager used the preto
principle in his favorite work?
I find myself constantly focusing on the
bottom five,
20 percent that causes 80,
95 percent of the team's poor
performance.
Oh,
that's easy.
Then managerial literature,
the solid managerial literature is
absolutely crystal clear on this.
Spend all your time with your highest
producers and put your lowest producers
where they can do the least amount of
damage.
The probability that as a manager,
you're going to be able to solve the
problems of the poorest five to 20
percent of your work.
A team is zero.
You just don't have the time or the
resources at your disposal.
So what you should definitely do in
order to increase performance is to
concentrate on your top performers.
I know that's not what managers do.
They do exactly what you say.
They focus on the bottom five to 20
percent,
but that's exactly the wrong thing to do
as a manager.
Focus on your best people.
They're hyper productive as you already
know.
So,
um,
you know,
maybe you need to reconceptualize the
way that you're interacting with your
people,
but you should have regular
conversations at least with those that
you think are outstanding.
Let them know that you really,
um,
what would you say that you're really
happy with their performance and see
what you can do to get obstacles the
hell out of their way because as a
manager,
essentially what you should be doing is
identifying the top performers and then
doing everything you can to clear out
the obstacles in their path.
That's the right way to think about it.
And also to give yourself enough time to
develop a medium to longterm plan and
start fighting fires on a day to day
basis.
You need at least 90 minutes a week to
think about where you want things to be
going into medium to long term.
So,
but I can't over emphasize the
importance of dealing with your top
productivity,
your talk,
your highest,
your most productive people.
That's where all the gains are.
That's where all the games are.
How are you doing?
Someone is asking you,
um,
you said some place that you felt like
you were at times dancing on broken
glass?
No,
I think I said that I was,
I always felt like I was dancing on
broken glass.
Are you getting enough rest?
And rnr is the food sensitivity getting
worked out?
I think maybe the food sensitivity thing
is getting worked out.
I think it's at the basis of,
of this depression that's been plaguing
my family for generations,
but I haven't figured out exactly what
it is yet.
I'm working very hard on that with my
daughter who also seems to have the same
problem and it is absolutely brutal.
It's absolutely brutal,
so I'm,
am I getting enough rest in rnr?
That's hard to say because with the
responses that I'd been having that
ignoring my health back,
it's,
it's hard to discriminate between risks
and R and r,
the lack of that and just getting
walloped by,
by eating what appears to be the wrong
thing.
So it's so funny because you know,
for years I was very skeptical of anyone
who was concerned about gluten
sensitivity and that sort of thing,
but I sure learned that that was
arrogant.
So yeah.
Well,
I found many times in my life that you
have to be aware of what you are
judgmental about because many things
come back to haunt you.
So
Dr Peterson,
do you have suggestions for how to make
a schedule that doesn't make you a
tyrant?
I've watched your previous videos,
but I'm struggling to make a weekly
schedule that is productive.
Hey Joshua,
start by making a weekly schedule that
you want really like,
imagine that you're designing your
schedule so that you can have the life
you want.
Just start with that,
like be easy on yourself to begin with.
You know,
you'll get better at it,
you can add more responsibilities as
you,
as you practice,
so,
so start by just scheduling and a few
things that you'd like to do and then
load it up over time,
but remember like get,
get your attitude,
right.
I'm using this schedule so that I can
have the days and the weeks and the
months that would make my life,
that would optimize my life,
right?
Not so that I should do what I need to
get done.
I mean,
obviously that's necessary,
but that's not the right goal.
So
what are your thoughts on students
taking adderall?
Are there any longterm effects?
Um,
there are long term studies of the
utility of adderall for attention
deficit disorder,
hyperactivity,
and the results are basically negative.
There is no evidence that the
medications help with academic
performance over the long run.
I think that adderall is an amphetamine.
It is addictive.
It can sensitize you to other dopamine
agonists.
So I would generally say it's something
to be avoided.
You also want to really watch it in
combination with marijuana for example,
or psychedelics because you can get
unlucky and trigger a psychotic episode
and that is not a good thing because
once you have one psychotic episode,
you're a bit on the broken side and it's
hard to put yourself back together.
So I would say use it sparingly if at
all.
It's not,
it's not a good plan and especially not
something good to be doing habitually.
So,
um,
any reading tips for becoming teachers
who don't want to be corrupted by the
current teacher education at the
universities?
Well I would say,
you know,
you can,
I have a reading list on my book,
on my website,
Jordan Peterson built column.
You could go look there.
I'm going to add some more books to read
as much classic literature as you can
read history,
like going to the libraries and,
and,
and look at great books programs.
That's what I would say.
And you have to educate yourself at the
university,
you know,
I mean,
that's always been the case and it's
even more the case now is,
is a
go back and go back and read great
literature,
Great Philosophy,
great thinkers,
and you will learn a tremendous amount
that way.
And I,
I think otherwise there's no way you can
avoid being corrupted by the current
teacher education at universities.
The education faculties are absolutely
dreadful.
Absolutely dreadful.
So
yeah,
George Gabriel on drugs says,
Jordan,
please help me.
I'm 99th percentile and openness and
zero with percentile and
conscientiousness.
Yeah.
Well how old are you?
That's the first thing.
If you're,
if you're young,
that's because younger people are less
conscientious.
So that's one thing to keep in mind if
you're very open like that,
you need to be doing something creative,
but you're going to have to learn how to
discipline yourself.
There's just no way around it.
And I would say go do the future
authoring program.
That's a good start.
And you'll have to learn how to schedule
your time then and how to get up at the
same time everyday.
And it's going to be a real struggle,
but you know,
you,
you can do it.
I've had students who were very high in
openness and low in conscientiousness as
graduate students and they disciplined
themselves.
You need to find something that you're
really interested in that you're willing
to pursue and then you have to hit it
hard.
So that's what I would say.
But do the future authoring program and
get yourself a plan and start the
implemented in every time you fall
astray,
then get back at it and you know,
you may have to build up your
conscientiousness over a number of years
and,
but it's worth doing.
So
my favorite Tom,
late song,
I really like cold water.
My son does a vicious version of cold
water,
but I really like cold water.
Um,
what else?
I like hoists that rag and that's pretty
decent song.
I like dozens of Tom Waits songs are
what else?
I have this mental tick where when
anyone asks me a question having to do
with a name names immediately damaged
from my mind anyways.
So I really like cold water.
I think that's a great song.
Is it wrong to turn down a promotion?
Is withdrawing from overwhelming
additional responsibility,
the equivalent of ignoring God's called
Abraham?
Not necessarily.
It depends on what it is that you're
doing.
Instead,
like if you have a better option,
then take the better option.
If you're afraid,
if it's just fear,
then you might want to find somebody to
talk to about that and,
and walk through your fears and make a
plan because you know it's possible that
it's the equivalent of ignoring God's
called Abraham.
Um,
you know,
if it's,
if it's pure fear,
then I would take a look at that.
But if you have a better option,
well,
you know,
it's up to you to decide the course of
your life.
So I wouldn't say that necessarily.
It's a bad thing,
you know,
not everyone wants overwhelming
responsibility at work and people are
interested in their private lives and
they're interested in their friendships
or their or what they do outside of
work.
So.
And I think that's all valid,
but if it's just fear,
then you need to find someone to talk to
and talk it through to make sure that
you're not throwing away an opportunity
that hey,
you know,
the other thing too is that,
what's your mood like?
Are you depressed?
Like maybe you're underestimating your
ability.
Somebody thinks you're worthy of
promotion.
And you have to remember too that when
you get promoted,
like almost everybody feels like an
imposter for the first year when they're
promoted to a new position because you
don't know what the hell you're doing.
You know,
so you're,
you're kind of acting out the role
before you're qualified to do it.
But that's okay.
You know,
it's,
it takes awhile to fit into a new skin.
So if you're a perfectionistic,
that's another thing to take into
account.
So,
all right,
I'm not very religious,
but your way of presenting the biblical
stories have given me a respect for
their function in society.
How do I address those who actively
oppose the wisdom on atheist principles?
Well,
look,
I think what you do is you say what
you've found carefully and if they
refuse to listen and just like put up an
impenetrable wall,
then you shut the hell up and go find
someone else to talk to.
You know,
that's the doctrine behind norb casting
pearls before swine.
There's,
there's a good rule,
which is if you're not being listened
to,
then shut up because you're not where
you think you are.
There's something going on that you
haven't put your finger on.
You're not in the place that you think
you're in.
And so you could also turn from
convincing to questioning,
you know,
if someone's very,
very set in their views,
instead of opposing them,
you can ask them to elucidate their
views and you can use that questioning
process.
It's like a socratic dialogue to dig
into their fundamental principles.
And sometime that's a good way of
opening up a space for dialogue.
So
what do you make of the gnostic gospels,
for example,
the Gospel of Thomas?
Well,
I've read the Gospel of Thomas and I
think it's a remarkable document.
There are things in it that are
extraordinarily powerful.
Uh,
I closed maps of meaning,
in fact,
the book I wrote in Nineteen Ninety nine
with a quotation from the gospel of
Thomas,
and it's really interesting too that the
first person you go to,
his hands on that Gospel was Carl Young,
which I think is an amazing example of
synchronicity,
right?
The first of the gnostic gospels that
was released into the broader world
ended up in Carl Jung's hands.
Absolutely amazing historical fact.
So
they seem to be to be extraordinarily
interesting.
Um,
and I read them,
I suppose in some ways the same way that
I read the Canonical Bible.
I'm trying to extract out what wisdom
there is in them or what wisdom I can
understand anyways and utilize it to the
degree that I can.
So
in one of your videos,
you mentioned about the power that
creates order from chaos,
but can also create chaos from
pathological ordered.
Can you expand and explaining the latter
one?
Well,
the logo logos,
that's the human capacity for
consciousness and,
and uh,
and communication and awareness.
And I think that it's,
it's actually the,
it's actually one of the fundamental
prerequisites for being itself,
right,
which is one of the things that makes me
different from a standard materialist I,
I don't believe that there can be being
without consciousness.
And so I think of consciousness as a
primary element of well of reality.
It's irreducible element of reality,
something like that,
a prerequisite for reality.
That's another way of thinking about.
And that's the logo.
So essentially,
and it's respect for the logo.
So I would say that's the deepest
doctrine of the,
of the biblical stories.
Now,
what is the logos do?
Well,
you can see this in Christ story most
particularly.
So Christ is often presented as a social
revolutionary.
All cast,
I suppose,
in the same mold as Moses,
Moses,
Moses opposed the Egyptian tyranny,
like Christ opposed the tyranny of the
Pharisees and the scribes.
And Moses produced tales as a
consequence of opposing the tyranny,
right?
He first chaos was the crossing of the
water and Moses was a master of water.
And that's the same symbolically as
being a master of chaos.
But after he freed the Hebrews from the
Egyptian tyranny,
while they entered a period that was 40
years long,
so the story goes of almost on almost
complete chaos,
right?
Abandonment in a desert,
tremendous moral confusion,
lack of direction and purpose.
And so sometimes the hero is the person
who makes order out of chaos.
But sometimes the hero is the person who
makes intermediary chaos out of an order
that's become too tyrannical.
And so it's,
it's best to think of the logo says the
forest that keeps order and chaos in
balance rather than transform rather
than generating order out of chaos or
chaos on the border because it did.
The logos operates to do one of those
two things depending on the situation.
And so it's frequently generating order
out of chaos because there's plenty of
chaos.
But there's also plenty of tyranny,
in which case the hero or the person who
embodies the logos is,
is,
is struggling to destroy the tyrannical
king and replace him with someone that's
more,
um,
it's playing a more reciprocal and
property negotiated game.
So,
all right,
everyone,
I'll answer like two more I would say.
And then I have to stop because I'm
getting fuzzy minded.
So
to what extent do you think your tips
for young people clean your room,
make a schedule,
read great books are predicated on your
own personality?
Well,
I think they're predicated on my
personality to some degree.
Um,
I think that a lot of my
conscientiousness such as it is,
has been learned.
I think I disciplined myself
particularly in graduate school.
So I don't think it was necessarily an
intrinsic part of my personality.
I think it's something that I learned to
do because I felt that I had something
that was worthwhile to do.
So
it's very difficult to answer it beyond
that because,
you know,
I am affected by my own personality
obviously.
Although I think that I give advice
that's pretty balanced across all the
dimensions,
you know,
like I think that you should be capable
of speaking in public fluently and that
you should be able to communicate with
groups of people.
I think that you should be able to be
solitary and work on your own.
So that covers extroversion and
introversion.
I think that working on control of
negative emotion is important.
Um,
and so that's partly dealing with
anxiety and stress and that's the
neuroticism dimension.
I think that you should be agreeable
when it's necessary and disagreeable
when it's necessary.
And so that's a broadening alone.
The agreeableness dimension.
I think that discipline is really
important in a complex society like
ours.
Discipline is extremely important and so
I think that being able to be
conscientious and reliable and orderly
to some degree is necessary,
but that you should be able to withdraw
from that when necessary so that you can
take a break and have some fun.
Um,
I think you could risk becoming over
committed to your work or two year
endeavor.
So I do think that that's something that
I risk
maybe I trained myself to be too
industrious.
It's certainly possible,
um,
openness.
Well that might be a place where I have
a personality predicated blind spot
because I'm very,
very high in openness and,
but I do believe that there's utility in
exposing yourself to the world of great
ideas.
And that's not for everyone,
you know,
I mean there are people who are
fundamentally conservative in their
orientation and more power to them I
suppose.
But um,
if you're going to read then you should
read great things and if you're
interested in the life of the intellect,
the philosophical life,
then then there's much to be learned by
reading great books.
So.
So I don't think that I'm overwhelmingly
biased with regards to my own
personality,
but you never know.
I mean,
it's hard.
It's hard for.
It's hard for someone to judge that
about themselves.
So
can one reason with a stalker.
My Stalker is highly intelligent and
rational.
Making him scarier.
I'm beginning to work with police and
lawyers.
But wondering if you have experienced in
this realm,
I would say
not knowing the specifics of your
situation.
No,
you can't really reason with the
stocker.
The stocker is already gone beyond the
realm of normal social behavior,
you know,
and I would say with most stockers,
assuming that you're dealing with the
genuine article,
that they tend to be a little bit on the
paranoid side or maybe a lot on the
paranoid side.
And the problem with people who are
paranoid is that they have adopted a
couple of axioms as absolutely fixed and
there's no shifting them.
So I would say,
you know,
I hate to give advice in a situation
like that,
but I wouldn't say that the probability
of using reason is precluded by the fact
of the stalking behavior.
So good luck with it.
That's very scary.
It's hard.
It's hard for people to be protected
from someone who's intent on following
them and perhaps making their life
miserable.
So
insights on how I would overcome or live
with my fear of Nellis and
disappointment in Matt,
Mike,
the novel.
Well,
here's something that you might
consider.
So when you're a child and you're naive,
then you trust people because you're
naive and you don't know any better and
you don't know that people can hurt you
unless you're a very unfortunate child.
So your,
your trust isn't a virtue.
It's just a sign of your innocence,
let's say.
And that kind of innocence isn't a
virtue,
it's just lack of experience.
But when you're older,
Mike,
courage or trust isn't,
is a hallmark of courage.
You extend your hand to people and you
extend your trust to people knowing full
well that you can be bit like you might
be bitten by a Cobra,
you can be betrayed and disappointed by
people,
but you extend your hand in trust
because of courage,
because you decide to take the risk and
by taking that risk,
you open the door to the best in people
and,
but you won't see that door open unless
you first take the step to trust.
And so I would say you have to practice
trusting people.
You know,
you have to share things that are
somewhat private.
You have to ask people for small favors
and trade small favors and you have to
that knowing full well that you can get
hurt.
So think about it as an act of courage
instead of,
um,
instead of naivety or,
or,
well,
instead of naive t,
let's leave it at that.
So that's what I would recommend.
All right everyone,
I'm going to stop.
So once again,
thank you very much for listening to me
tonight.
I hope that it went well.
Um,
I can never tell when I'm doing this,
but they seem to be popular.
I'm very pleased that you all
spend so much time putting these
questions together and,
and watching my videos and listening to
me,
I,
I'm genuinely and continually amazed and
grateful about that.
So,
um,
I hope you all have a good month and
that you continue working as hard as you
can on putting yourself together because
the more together people there are,
the better things are going to go for
everyone.
And it's very important,
as I pointed out before,
that you get your individual life in
order.
So good night everyone and uh,
keep up the good work man.
See Ya.